-Now, I hope this
stereotype is true --
or it seems to me
that it's true --
that Australians travel
like nobody else.
-Well, it's so far from
everywhere else that when
you leave, you may as well
just keep going for a long time.
-Yeah. Yes, it's true.
Like, when you meet
an Australian on vacation,
you realize they're like
six months into it
and they have six months to go
-Yes.
-That's how it's
always been for me.
But you -- So, you traveled
lot when you were younger.
And, now, explain to me that -
You would shave your head?
Is this a thing that is true
-I've shaved my head five times.
-And what brought you to
shave your head?
-I find it very cleansing.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I mean,
the first time I did it,
it was my 25th birthday.
-Yeah.
-I was in Mexico.
I had too much tequila and
I trusted this guy.
Kind of plump hands.
I thought, "He's doing it.
The next time I did it was
for a friend's --
Actually, I been in
Nepal and India with her,
and her fashion show
was inspired by
the hill tribes of Nepal.
So, she asked me to be in it
and I shaved my head then.
Then I met my husband,
and three days into what was -
What we now know is
a relationship,
I shaved my head to test him
to see if he
still liked me
when I look like that.
-Wait.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait. Three...
-Days.
-Three days?
-Yeah.
-Why did you want to
test him so quickly?
-Well, I could have
done it on day two.
-Yeah, that's true.
You gave him a grace period.
-Yeah.
-So, that's three.
Do you remember the other ones
-I did one in
a Peter Greenaway film.
-Okay.
-And then, more recently -
I think it was about
five years ago now -- I made a
film called "Miss You Already"
with Drew Barrymore.
-Yeah.
-And it was shaved for
my character, who had cancer
-And, so, now do you think tha
you -- Is that it?
Do you think you're done now
-Well, my hair, a few weeks ago,
was this long.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I could be bald right now
but I decided
I should only go to here.
-There's one last thing.
I believe you've seen it,
but I do want to show it.
Our friend John Early --
he's a wonderful comedian.
And he was a guest on
this show, and one thing
he really wanted to do
on this show
was his Toni Collette
impression.
He felt it was very strong
And he does an impression of you
in "The Sixth Sense."
And I played --
In the clip, I took over -
-Were you Haley?
-I was Haley Joel Osment.
And he was Toni Collette.
And if you would just like t
look over there,
we would love to show you
John Early's impression of you
-What did ask her?
-[ Voice breaking ]
I asked her....
-Oh, my God. What is that?
-...do I make her proud?
-He's hilarious.
-He is hilarious.
Next time, you can do an
impression of him.
We will make sure
we give you time.
Thank you so much.
This is Toni Collette,
everybody.